create doesn't go anywhere  whoa trick he missed this special event  you missed  king of eight Knight H7  you could see the tiniest of actress  Daryl  nice little Fork  at H7 blitzed out  what's the clock situation Magnus is 21  seconds and food  kiril has 27 seconds and no food so it  should be a favorite he's also winning  on the board yeah but I think that's  necessarily minus can't stop eating I  think more or less when he decides  anytime  I think so yeah  that's  hmm  kiro's pretty fast  yeah  so is Mr Carlson  it's amazing how good these people are  with just pre-moving every move not  hanging too much stuff  yeah you only see this in five zero the  guys are hating about it that's an art  form look how Carol converted this  it's beautiful with all three moves  very very impressive yep  yeah you were getting some Flack today  from the chickens about your your choice  I mean five plus zero